now like to introduce um april st james
who is here on behalf of united states
senator
uh jackie rosen april
welcome hi everyone thank you so much
for having me
um on behalf of senator rosen's office
we are delighted to be you know invited
to participate in the second
annual uh nevada advocacy recovery day
so thank you so much for having us the
speakers today have been
tremendous in sharing their personal
stories of loss of struggle and
as we all know um advocacy
for for yourselves and uh in the
recovery process is something that
is lifelong right um it's not something
that
we're going to be doing uh once meeting
with a legislator
and uh and that's it the work is never
done we're always discovering new
issues and so without people like
yourselves
you know reaching out to our offices
letting us know where are these holes
where
where are their needs in the state of
nevada
we can't get anything done without you
it all starts with you um one example
that i like to always bring
up is you know you're all very important
to this process
um and you know our former president
barack obama he started out as an
organizer
you know if if he can take you know his
advocacy
for special issues and organize all the
way up to the top
there's nothing that you all can't do
your
personalized stories are what actually
affect the legislation
and without you nothing uh gets
accomplished and so we truly want to
encourage
all of you to really believe in yourself
you already have the courage to be on a
call like this
speak in front of people continue that
courage
continue to tell us about the things
that you need from
us so that we can better improve the
state of nevada
for everyone one of the
the pieces of legislation that senator
rosen just recently worked on and i'm
sure all of you are very aware of
is the american recovery plan which is
sending you know 2.9 billion dollars
to the state of nevada
in order to help contribute to governor
sisilak's
every nevadan recovery plan so we are
very very
happy to see where those dollars will be
going and um it was exciting to hear his
announcements today
and so if um if there are issues that
you would like to advocate about
we are always open to hear what you need
from us
so on behalf of senator rosen thank you
for all that you do
keep the courage to keep talking about
these
issues through the highs through the
lows
because that's where real change happens
so thank you so much for having us
and then lastly uh we did want to
present a certificate of congressional
recognition
um to the foundation for recovery
i'll be sending this along oh gosh
we can see it yeah my background is kind
of
forcing that to disappear but it will be
sent along later today and we are so
happy to recognize what a wonderful
group
of individuals you all are and the great
work that you're doing to contribute to
a healthier nevada so thank you so much
thank you april and i just saw that
senator scott hammond uh
was able to join us from from his busy
day things are going
you know uh fast in carson city so
senator
uh hammond thank you for joining us
today i'd like to uh welcome you to
recovery advocacy day
thank you very much ryan it's a pleasure
to be here uh you know i've
i like to say that uh i've become a
little bit more active in what you all
are doing and it's mostly because of
what you said
i was privileged to be able to hear a
speech that you gave a couple years ago
now
and it kind of changed my mind that and
you know i
as a former teacher i've had several
students that uh i made an impact on my
life and one of them
you know a young man that when he uh
when he left school he played
i think junior college baseball in
florida and sort of got wrapped up into
everything that you've talked about in
the past and
he went to the pill mill central right
uh he got caught
got injured and then was uh all of a
sudden put on
uh some medication he couldn't get off
and and then that led to another thing
led to
unfortunately an addiction and
and really unfortunately it took his
life so uh you know when
when you started speaking um a lot of
that sort of
fell on me resonated with me and uh and
it just led me to
to want to do more and uh you know last
session i actually
i had a bill uh it didn't make it out of
the
uh senate uh that then uh the uh we
with the help of senator ratty we
attached to one of her bills that made
it out of the senate over to the
assembly and we attached all the words
and
uh the the meaning behind it and passed
it uh
as part of her bill as well so uh it's
great to to be able to contribute to
that but a lot of that
the courage i got i got from you so you
know it's
nothing extraordinary it's just uh i
think a lot of people
working together and the the synergy
that we create uh starts to
demystify and uh starts to allow people
to
realize that uh you know those people
out there who are
addicted um they're our brothers and
sisters they're our moms or dads and
they're
people who need to to be helped and
there there's nothing wrong with them
they just need a little bit of help to
get out of the situation they're in so
a lot of that is from from you from the
book that you wrote
i read that uh cover to cover and and uh
you know
started to work on understanding a
little bit more
so i appreciate the opportunity to come
here and talk to you all about that
thank you senator and um everything that
i've learned and done and spoken up is
because of this community and the folks
that are on this call
um who gave me the courage to to do the
work as a recovery advocate and our
stories are
are so powerful and so important and can
have
uh such a tremendous amount of impact in
uh the recovery community as a whole
we are mindful of that impact and uh
thank you thank you senator for
for joining us today and for taking time
out of your
schedule and we look forward to working
with you uh throughout the rest of this
session
uh and moving forward um with that said
i
i want to thank all the legislators uh
and special guests and
and a special shout out to governor
sislak uh
for the announcement this morning we're
really excited about that and looking
uh to continuing to to build on recovery
friendly workplaces here in nevada
you know to help close us out today uh i
am
super grateful um and really uh
jazzed up to introduce one of my good
friends uh joseph
lms green joseph is um
undoubtedly one of the best spoken word
artists
in the country uh and also uh proudly
living in long-term recovery
joseph's works joseph's work focuses on
intentional diversity social justice
radical love and the sacred belief that
our stories
have the power to connect inspire us
the way that very few things can so
without further ado
i'd like to introduce joseph lms green
[Music]
hi everybody um just want to make sure
everyone can hear me
thumbs up brian awesome it is
my pleasure and honor to be here at what
is undoubtedly one of the most uh
important events that i've had the
ability to be at while in the middle of
this pandemic
i am all of those things that that ryan
said and i really appreciate that very
warm introduction
um but i above all of that
i am a father of two sons and the reason
why i mention that is because
as we go through this process
of legislature and and and getting
people
inspired to go out and make a difference
and
and and speak to their their their
senators and and and
to talk about how recovery has
made a difference in their life and how
important it is to support people
out in our communities i think about the
reason
why so many of us are here i think about
the reason why so many of us have been
inspired to step into uncomfortable
spaces
have uncomfortable conversations to take
our personal stories
and to highlight them in the hopes that
it will inspire
the the very change that we know can
save
lives and so when i thought about what i
wanted to share with you all here today
i i decided that i wanted to share a
poem about
my family and my family's story with
addiction
and recovery and
i do this as a as a hope as a dream as a
wish that i put up into the air that
i will be able to stop the
cycle in my family the way that my
father was able to do it
for himself and then eventually with me
and
i hope that what we've gone through will
be a light
for my children and i encourage everyone
to embrace and understand and know and
be willing to share their stories
when it has the chance to save
a life and so this poem is called
life is short and is dedicated to
my father and everyone who has been
inspired
by a family member to get into this
fight
in the hospital bed i helped him turn
so the cancer medication could spread
more evenly
his eyes welled and cracked
like a fortune cookie the piece of paper
inside read
life is short but being alive
is the longest thing you will ever do
proceed accordingly
if i'd attempted this homage to my
father 20 years ago
it probably would have consisted more of
those intangibles that
drove me away hate and blame more than
just mere symptoms of childhood angst
but the language
i learned to explain how my father's
absence from my formative years made me
feel you see
i once considered my father's dna to be
a cancer in me
knowing the helix to be doubled i never
dreamed of losing myself completely
only half a man now i realized my
thinking
was the cancer forgiveness is medication
i'm still waiting for it to spread
evenly
always with the wrong bottle in hand
from birth my
father showed me the image of addicts
resemble something like a court jester
juggling knives
one blade for family one blade for work
one blade for marriage one for the
military that never treated him
equally one for the father that died
when he was ten
another for the mother that was never
the same all the while
spiraling down towards the greatest come
to jesus moment
ever sixteen-year-old son in the back
seat as wife picks him up from jail
after his second dui
my father has been in recovery for 25
years now
my father's poison was alcohol mine
was cocaine they say parents want
children to grow up
achieve feats greater than their own i
don't believe this
is what they had in mind i've spent
years mortified of mirrors for having
his image
being reflected back on me start a new
lightness at the bottom of empty whiskey
bottles and clear plastic baggies
mainline hate and blame until i became
so high
i had nowhere to go rock bottom in the
sky
i landed in my father's arms
through falling i've come to realize
just as i did not
my father did not ask for this
predilection towards addiction that hate
and blame are just new ways to get high
for those of us not ready to change
and that which took him half a lifetime
only took me 10 years
because he has shown me what recovery
looks like
what dignity reinstated looks like what
a future
not hunted by regret looks like i
refused to be another cautionary tale
of a son who couldn't forgive his father
because he couldn't
forgive himself traveling down route 95
stopped
by a cop for going 95 exclaiming out of
the window of my
car that like all men my father is dying
and like most men i never told them i
understood
never told them i knew one of those
blades he juggled had love for family
inscribed in it
never said i forgave him as i hope he
has forgiven me never said
thanks never said i'm proud of you
and though i realize neither side of
this
reflection will ever be perfect
i'm no longer scared of mirrors
because life is short
but being alive is the longest thing you
will ever do
proceed accordingly
thank you for having me i hope you were
inspired by these words
and i look forward to seeing you all in
person very soon
have a great day wow
thank you joseph thank you for those
words thank you for your friendship
thank you for the work that you do for
this community uh
day in and day out and for your
engagement uh with the recovery advocacy
project and there's so many just like
phenomenal
um projects that you're involved in just
a
you know joke when i was i i have to
tell this story really quick
as we go out close out joseph knows it's
coming
i first met joseph when i i was
traveling around the country
um with garrett uh hade who many of you
know
uh when i was early in my recovery in
2016 and wanted to learn what recovery
advocacy was and what was happening
around the country and and uh garrett
and i didn't have a place to stay and
and we ended up because we had no money
i mean we were just traveling around in
an rv
and we ended up in washington dc uh
where joseph was living at the time
and uh he offered up his his couch to us
and um we stayed with joseph i think for
like two or three days while we were
there and got to know him and and the
rest is history and it has just been
you know the pleasure of my lifetime uh
to get to know you and grow this bond
with you so so thank you for the work
you do joseph and i wanna
um everybody who's here with us today uh
for joining us thank you for your work
thank you for your passion and thank you
for
continuing to share your voices for
impact the recovery
movement here in nevada without a doubt
is making tremendous strides and that is
because
of each and every one of you
please join us at the recovery advocacy
project help us
get across the finish line this
legislative session you can learn more
about us
at recoveryvoices.com until then
please stay safe stay healthy and
keep standing up for recovery in your
communities
i want to pass it back to sean to close
us out
thank you everybody thank you so much
ryan
you know i remember two years ago during
the 80th legislative session
and advocates like everyone here today
showed up in carson city for the
inaugural recovery advocacy day
i never thought that we'd be coming
together this session on zoom
but i call it a great success and i'm
thankful for everyone who participated
today
remember that we are the solution
keep advocating for what's right and
never be ashamed
one call to action that i have for
everyone is to get
involved reach out to one of the many
panelists
partner organizations foundation for
recovery
or the recovery advocacy project to
start making a difference in your
community
whether it's becoming a community
trainer helping with outreach
distributing naloxone
providing peer recovery support or
volunteering on a warm line
unfortunately there is no shortage of
work to be done
and we can use all the help we can get
have a wonderful
rest of your afternoon and thank you
everyone for joining us today
for the 2021 recovery advocacy day